Jake here it is III 2017 and we're
checking out an indie game called away
I'm here with Jim and this is his game
would you like to describe to me what
what we're about to look at first things
I want to apologize because I have a
really bad english i'm french so sorry
this game is called away is a feel-good
first-person shooters we play a kid is
not a hero is a little bit useless is
not good at fighting but is good at
making one things is good at making
friends so each time you meet a new
characters you can work with him or even
eat if you want to play silly creators
like a trees in this game you need to
find what your parent do for a living
because you live at your parents house
when parents house but that's made 10
years that they tell you that now don't
be worried i will come back but hey
what's up ends alright well let's get
into it
I think what stood out to me right away
is just the art style I mean it what
were the inspirations for a different
looks like some anime inspirations but
it also kind of finds its own unique
style Oh with my co-workers over area
because we are only two on this game we
are a big fan of the first Dragon Ball
in France where we were young there were
a lot of Japanese show on TV and a lot
of manga and animation and I think that
that has inspired us a lot for the qd7
fear element are in 3d but also
character are in 2d art styles and yeah
as you can see there is a frog in the
foyer but it's okay oh by the way you
can talk with a frog and you can talk
with the dog and you understand them
that it's okay in real life this is like
I like the I mean the one thing that did
stand out while I was playing two or one
of many things was the character design
even watching the trailer when I saw the
trailer and we were looking at this I
was like this is a game I want to see
more of like I didn't play too much but
I made it outside into I made it outside
and ran into the the guy his face was
all messed up he had the construction
helmet on
Oh mr. smooth man yeah it worked for
lobby works this is a company will dig
up all the all the environment and mess
it up your else is a good guy but yeah
it maybe I've purchased arms in the
weird liquid in the case something
happens so those are the grandparents
where is this character's parents yeah
this is the story where are the parents
as okay they do something they're not at
home there is no drama
they are not dead or these kind of
things it's okay but they do something
more interesting than staying at home by
the way this is your dog
yeah max he looks like a good boy yeah
he is a good boy you have a good stick
so how long does it take to create a
character model like that because they
all seem very frantic very detailed but
oh oh you go see grandpa okay because
grandpa call in to to come back to the
kitchen and this is one of the main
mechanics of our game each time you you
leave your house or you leave a dungeon
you need to find a way to go to the end
of the game so each time we wanted to
supplier have a really great journey and
see new stuff all the time
so once you get out here how big is the
world exactly the world is a lot of
separate what we called open area each
open area of his own object types and
they you go from open area to a dungeon
and from a dungeon you go to multiple
other open area and it's ways come back
to the end of the game and if you want
to open a new area you need to have a
number of staff you have a u1 stars each
time you meet a new characters and you
make a new friends okay yeah I noticed
walking through the house there's a lot
of doors that were blocked off and look
like I needed a certain oh yeah else is
all add of father game each room gives
you a bonus for the start of your
journey okay so is this is this sort of
permit death if you die you started
beginning the friends are the main kid
the main head oh yes yes if so if the
kids die yeah you come back to home and
you need to restart your journey there
is some kind of rogue like elements in
the game you start game after game and
you keep all your money your grenade and
your number of stars and the people that
you already meet women value so you
don't need to to to answer to swears to
their question to repeat as M
all the characters are so great yeah and
this is a new friend okay new friends I
like to power-ups so each time you use a
friend that's consumed is energy and if
you have normal energy it is exhausted
and you can't use in anymore
okay so this is each character have
special ability I mean it looks like
this guy's got a different weapon
yeah it's each friend of his own special
abilities like shooting fireballs having
a apparent petal on mines on the floors
so meet new friends is cool you're more
powerful but each time you use special
abilities that consumes energy if no
more energy they are exhausted and you
can't use them anymore so switching
between characters is cool because you
are not powerful but you need to take
the right decision - did I really need
to shoot another fireball or need did I
need to come back to the kids so I also
like the broken that's nice yeah when
you switch from characters you see the
world through the eyes of your own
you'll new friends so there are certain
areas that you wouldn't be able to get
to unless you had a certain character or
is pretty much the world open just
having different character will be know
each can each character when you talk to
with characters they give you some
information about the world story of the
game and what's happened in this world
okay
sorry about to go into a dungeon here
yeah it's one of the first cave we see a
little bit of monsters come yeah yeah
yeah that's better
this is quaint you can buy some items in
at the shopkeepers and this is one of
the free level free switch of the of the
area in this area you need to find the
free switch to open the gate of the
dungeon and Bill's few your journey oh
and by the way each time you enter a
dungeon or cave as the the game pcap one
of the different level we do and that's
but random in the game and each time you
start a new run ok you are in the same
area but you enter ok and this is a new
cave this is we wanted to add player see
all the time new things new stuff and
don't be on whale world to the end of
the game can we be friendly tree that
yeah yeah we can talk to him but because
we don't have a new slot available a lot
of friendships we can't work with him
maybe maybe there is some Cuba
friendships at the shopkeeper but I
don't know this game oh by the way this
is mr. smooth man every bit everything
is under control
yeah I'm little bit worried about him so
once you get all three switches I take
it back door back there was the one that
would open yeah
so let's see what's a pen in this cave
by this let's give you some earth for
the kids oh by the way don't don't ask
me why mushroom drops bombs but the
drops bombs so with the main kid is his
only weapon a stick yes these more
focused I'm using different characters
use their different weapons rather than
yeah and by the way because we we are we
have run in this game each time you
fight monsters you an experience point
and at the end of your run you can
unlock new skills and abilities for the
kids but only for the kids okay so the
must you play the most the kids become
powerful and so must you have friends so
must you become powerful oh by the way
and all the content of the chests are
randomly chosen between gold fire rocks
and earth cool so when when can we
expect this game to come out we expect
to release the game q1 next year we plan
to release it on ps4 Nintendo switch
Xbox and Xbox one not the first Xbox and
PC - great
well thank you so much for coming by
yeah thanks and that was a way for more
indie game coverage and more coverage of
e3 make sure to hit that subscribe
button thanks for watching